today on the matt welsh show we will
play the one clip that puts the debate
over disney grooming to rest and proves
once and for all beyond a shadow of it
out that they do have an agenda to groom
and indoctrinate children also elon musk
is now officially on the verge of
becoming twitter's new owner and
democrats move to legally bar marjorie
taylor green from running for
re-election if you can't beat him in the
ballot box just take him to court
apparently plus taylor lorenz comes up
with the lamest possible excuse to
justify doxxing lubes of tick-tock and
in our daily cancellation a stay-at-home
dad weeps over the fact that his son is
becoming quote unquote traditionally
masculine what's a gender-bending dad
supposed to do in that situation we'll
talk about all that and more today on
the matt walsh show
[Music]
just like the foundation of this great
country is the constitution the
foundation of your family should be your
faith and your beliefs so i have a
serious question for you if something
should happen to you or your spouse who
do you trust to instill those same core
beliefs and values in your children
do you think it's uh the same person the
state would assign them to
if you don't have a will in place you
have no say in the future of your
children let that sink in for a minute
and if you're single and you don't think
you need a will you could not be more
wrong a will allows you to establish
advanced directive and medical power
attorney do you really want to leave the
burden of deciding life support or not
to your family members or close friends
of course not a will allows you to
clearly communicate to your loved ones
what your wishes are regarding your
health if you haven't made one yet
you're not alone but we're going to make
it easy for you at epicwheel.com when
you use promo code walsh we are so
excited that they're partnering with us
at the daily wire they're protecting our
staff and their families let them
protect yours epicwheel.com promo code
walsh this is how easy it is you can
secure your future in as little as five
minutes with a complete will package
starting at 119
and when you use promo code walsh you'll
save 10 epic will.com this will be the
most important five minutes you spend
today you know very often in our world
today we are told that we must
disbelieve our lying eyes truths that
are right in front of us plain as day
are to be rejected as mere figments of
our imagination the most obvious
realities become conspiracy theories
statements a basic fact or propaganda we
run fact checks on self-evidence
certitudes and the fact check corrects
the record reality is not reality we are
informed the sun is not in the sky water
is not wet there is no gravity
we're not living on planet earth
nothing that you see is real
the self-assigned arbiters of truth
assure us
don't rely on your own common sense
close your eyes which so often deceive
you anyway and let them guide you to and
fro let them be your window into the
world
they will tell you what is real and what
isn't
and they
our culture's truth deciders have
decided that all of the recent talk
about grooming is absurd outrageous
offensive bigoted it's all just a bunch
of anti-gay fear-mongering they say and
the claim that disney disney of all
companies disney not disney the claim
that they're actively grooming and
sexualizing children is the most
ludicrous falsehood of all they insist
that's why they tell us the move in
florida last week to take away disney's
special tax privileges was a
catastrophic overreaction
worse it was an all-out assault on the
first amendment somehow
i mean disney has no constitutional
right to the extra privileges afforded
it by florida but
now that it has those privileges taking
them away is unconstitutional we're told
it's an unnecessary act of retribution
disney didn't do anything to deserve it
to deserve this
poor helpless disney that
200 billion damsel in distress
disney now needs its own prince charming
to come rescue it but unfortunately
disney declared years ago that those
kinds of characters are misogynistic
retrograde gender essentialist
and so there is no one left to save them
they are abandoned to the clutches of
the dastardly desantis a man who we are
reminded
completely made up this whole issue of
disney grooming children that is
entirely fictional
and yet
there are of course many examples we can
point to and have pointed to many times
recently of disney endorsing encouraging
and often actively engaging in
predatory grooming practices towards
children
we've gone through the partial catalog
enough to prove the point i think
but
we've missed one example
one example so disgusting and twisted
and over the top
that it's really the only one we need
the conversation could begin and end
right here
anyone defending disney
anyone claiming that the grooming label
is unfair or overboard
anybody including people on the right
panicking over florida's revocation of
disney's legal privileges should be
confronted with this clip
this is from an episode of good morning
america on abc which is of course owned
by disney
because when we're talking about disney
we're not just talking about disney
world and mickey mouse and uh the little
mermaid we're talking about all of the
media properties that disney owns
like abc
now what you're about to see happened on
live tv
on a major network
in front of a live studio audience
i didn't dig this up from the darkest
fringes of the internet this is as
mainstream as it gets
it's what disney promotes and supports
so here's the time when good morning
america featured an 11 year old boy in
drag
the child's stage name is desmond is
amazing
and everyone in the building including
the hosts including michael strahan is
one of the hosts
seem to very much agree that what you're
about to see is indeed amazing
here it is
please welcome desmondapolis aka desmond
is amazing
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
i love that you love root beer caffeine
free
i can get on board with that my mom
doesn't like me drinking caffeine
does it make you hyper
yeah me too they don't like when i drink
caffeine either
but jasmine you're one of the youngest
and first drag queen slash kids
i've heard that you've gotten messages
from young adults who look up to you for
being who you are
what are some of the notes you've gotten
some of the notes i've gotten are like
that you inspire me very much and i wish
i could have had the support that you
have um when i was a child
now
if you're listening to the audio podcast
you have been spared the worst of what
we just experienced altogether
um though you can't fully appreciate
just how dark and deranged it was
because desmond the 11 year old drag kid
quote unquote prances out
on stage in women's clothes
makeup caked on his face
dances for the adoring crowd of grown
adults at one point lays himself out
prostrate on the ground on the stage
while creepy michael strahan stares and
claps
then he sits down for a lengthy
interview
and later in this segment um this
segment that was aired on disney's abc
even though disney totally is not trying
to groom children at
all later in the segment three adult
drag queens are brought out on stage
with desmond in their full
cross-dressing costumes woman face fully
on and they proceed to give desmond
gifts of makeup and quote-unquote dance
classes watch
you guys want to tell us what's out here
well i i see i i drew desmond a little
green-haired lady it's it's it's for you
it's to bring you good luck and
prosperity in your future
[Applause]
and to eat iceberg lettuce good roughage
okay there you go
tomatoes and cucumbers absolutely
and i brought you a gift basket of some
of my favorite actually you know what
let me actually hand it to you because i
think you need to have it in your hands
it is some of my favorite makeup
essentials that i use always
i will never understand
so many things about what we're seeing
here but um one of them is that is is
how every woman is not insulted
when they see
the drag queens and i know so many women
are in fact
but every woman should be insulted
because because i mean leaving aside the
worst part about this which is the fact
that there's a kid there we'll get back
to a second but um you see that and like
that's what they think of you that's
that's their impression of you
it is no different from blackface it is
female blackface
it is a it is a mockery of womanhood
this is what they think
you are
this is their female impression
and if it seems cartoonish and degrading
that's because it is
and that's how they see femininity as a
degraded cartoonish
thing
by the way if you're wondering where the
father is in all of this
um surprisingly
or maybe not surprisingly he is in the
picture he's literally in the picture
he's in the audience during this segment
he's one of the greasy disgusting old
men staring and clapping while the young
boys paraded around and cross-dressing
burlesque gear
desmond may as well be wearing a
sandwich board sign which announces i am
a sexual abuse victim because his abuse
is on full display for all to see and
the audience loves every minute of it
and abc loves it and disney loves it
now those who wish to mitigate and
minimize this will point out that this
segment aired back in 2018. this is not
new
it's old news
i've already been told this today after
i posted this segment on twitter
people say this is old news why you
posting this
because to them apparently child sexual
abuse doesn't matter if it happened a
few years ago
but maybe they'd have a point that its
relevance to the current news cycle is
minimized if
there had already been an overwhelming
public outrage about this spectacle and
everybody involved was fired and disney
had issued a public apology
and there was already a reckoning of
that sort but no such reckoning occurred
nobody was fired
nobody apologized
there wasn't even any real backlash
michael strahan got a major contract
extension last year after this everybody
involved rode happily into the sunset
except for desmond himself who is still
being paraded around and used as a prop
by the lgbt left and his evil
exploitative ghoulish abusive parents
desmond has been sent into gay clubs to
dance for money
that's a real thing
this child in drag has danced at gay
clubs at night
while grown adult
gay men throw money at him on stage
he's appeared in videos with adult gay
men where he pantomimes snorting
ketamine off of his hand
something that no 11 year old should
know how to do or be aware of
um just for reference here's that moment
anyone can do drag
everyone can do drag everyone your mom
can do jack
what has this world come to it's come to
a world where drought kids actually
exist and people do ketamine on a couch
and people do ketamine on my couch
yeah so he's uh so that's during some
kind of facebook live or something and
he's done a lot of these where he's
where he appears with adult um
cross-dressing men
and uh very often in the videos he
appears to be on drugs i mean he appears
this 11 year old boy
who very clearly appears to be drugged
and in that video he now that's not
something that 11 year old
should know anything about do ketamine
on a couch and then he but why was he
doing that because at the very least he
sees it happen all the time
and i think we can assume that he's that
a lot more than just seeing it has
occurred
so this boy is quite clearly being
drugged abused and exploited in front of
the whole world
and um nothing is being done to stop it
on the contrary disney is there to
celebrate and promote it
meanwhile the whole concept of drag kids
and the mixing of drag queens and kids
with things like drag queen story hour
that's only become more mainstream more
common more popular since 2018.
once the left learned that it could put
something like that on a network
television morning show
that was actually a a pivotal i believe
a pivotal moment in our culture was that
lots of people never knew that it even
happened
but that they could put that on good
morning america
um and there's no backlash
because of it
nobody even complains well they knew
they could get away with a whole lot
more
and that's what they set out to do
disney learned this lesson also
the only problem with the current
backlash against grooming especially
disney's grooming of kids isn't that
it's too harsh or over the line or too
vengeful or unconstitutional it's none
of those things
the problem is that it's many years too
late boys like desmond have already been
destroyed while so many conservatives
were distracted or too afraid to say
anything now that we're finally clued in
there is very little we could do
that we could possibly do in holding
disney and other groomers accountable
that would be truly overboard
certainly taking away their special
cushy privileges
doesn't even come close to that
i mean
we could forget about everything else
that disney has done
okay we could put all of that to the
side we could skip over everything and
just focus on this one segment on one
episode of good morning america in 2018
and that would be all by itself
way more than enough to justify
everything that's happening to disney
right now
the only problem would be that it took
too long
taking away tax benefits should be the
least of it
why should a company be able to keep its
tax benefits after putting that on the
air
you answer me that
i want any conservative who has a
problem with this to answer me that why
should they be able to keep their tax
privileges while doing that
in a sane and just and healthy society
all of the adults involved
would would you know the tax privileges
would be the least of it because all the
adults involved in producing and filming
that segment would be in jail if we were
a sane society
desmond's parents would have life
sentences and solitary confinement
at a minimum
the backlash against disney would have
been so overwhelming and intense as to
totally bankrupt and destroy the company
that's what should have happened
what should still happen
instead we have to settle for making
them pay taxes
you know that's not such a steep price
to pay
when you think of it like that now let's
get to our five headlines
[Music]
all right parents listen up we've all
seen the countless examples of how
radical radical leftists have been
destroying american schools it's no
longer just about the terrible math and
reading levels now radical left teachers
birthed from liberal universities are
forcing gender indoctrination in
kindergarten they're teaching lessons on
white guilt they're pushing critical
race theory in classrooms we know all
the things that they're doing since
covet parents have exposed dozens of
violent and sexually explicit books and
libraries cala school boards have done
nothing and the doj treated concerned
parents like terrace if you want a real
education for your child you need to
check out freedom project academy unlike
public schools freedom project academy
has perfected live online learning over
the course of a decade they're built on
judeo-christian values and classical
curriculum dedicated to providing
mastery of subject matter not propaganda
so go to
freedomforschool.com that's
freedomforschool.com and request your
free information packet today the
average high school graduate is reading
at a 7th grade level think about that
for a second
don't let that happen to your child
classes are filling up so please don't
wait until the last minute that's
freedomforschool.comfreedomforschool.com
all right um so i got to ask you this
real quick so tell me if i deserve to be
bullied for this over the weekend
my wife once again was
stalking harassing and fat shaming me
and this time she told everybody
that on saturday i had six slices of
pizza in one sitting with nacho cheese
now here's the thing and i'm getting i'm
getting a lot of harassment over this
the thing is out of context
that sounds pretty bad you know it
sounds like gluttonous and disgusting
and reprehensible
but that's why you need to wait until
you get all the facts before you believe
rumors on the internet especially if
they're started by my wife here are the
facts
i did actually eat all of that
but i still rate the claim false because
crucial details are missing and i've
learned from the fact checkers you can
do that
something could be totally true but if
it's not if not all the facts are given
then it's false now so this is false
because here are the facts we ordered a
bunch of pizza
we had a lot left over
i did my part to eat more because
as my parents always told me when i was
a kid there are starving kids in china
and somehow they are helped when you
stuff your fat face even after you're
already full
as far as the nacho cheese i'd never
done that before but the pizza place
where we ordered it they asked would you
like nacho cheese with the pizza i never
no one's ever asked me that at a pizza
place before what am i gonna say no
somebody asks if you want nacho cheese
as a side no matter what your meal is
are you gonna say no one would say no to
that so you say yes and i tried it and
uh frankly it was a revelation
i could not recommend it enough
nacho cheese and pizza it changed my
life
my life and my waistline will
never be the same again
all right maybe slightly bigger news
than me eating slice of pizza is this
from reuters twitter is poised to agree
to a sale um to elon musk for around 43
billion dollars in cash which was the
best and final offer that he made
a couple weeks ago and originally they
said they want to know part of it um at
least the board the board said that
um
twitter may announce the uh the deal
later on monday once its board has met
to recommend the transaction to twitter
shareholders the sources said it's
always possible the deal collapses at
the last minute the source sources added
musk the world's richest person
according to a tally by forbes is
negotiated by twitter at a personal
capacity and tesla is not involved in
the deal now listen
i'm not ready to to build any statues to
elon musk just
yet well i take that back i think i i
would build them i i would build a
statute of elon musk right now for no
other reason than how offensive it would
be to the left like if i was president i
would commission a 70-foot
statue of elon musk
like just maybe right in the middle of
washington dc and i would put it
alongside the 70-foot statue of
christopher christopher columbus that
i'm going to build
and the statue of stonewall jackson
murdering an endangered panda with a gun
which will be labeled assault rifle on
the side of it um that's my campaign
promise my only campaign promise is that
i'm going to do that
the point is aside from annoying the
left
i would not be building monuments to
elon musk but i do think that he will
obviously go down
as one of the most significant humans of
of our century
and on top of that
he's one of the only rich guys in the
world right now that i can think of
who's actually doing
cool things with his money not just cool
things but things that are making the
world a better place
like let's let's contrast this with mark
zuckerberg who's who's uh not the
richest guy in the world you know he's
only worth like 100 billion rather than
200 billion or whatever it is
um it's practically a popper compared to
elon musk but he's taking all of that
and his big project is the metaverse
and so what he wants to do instead is um
you know he noticed that that people are
wasting their lives on the internet
and that the internet has taken over our
lives especially for kids and so his
idea is let's take that situation
and make it a million times worse let's
make it exponentially worse
people have forsaken almost
they have all but forsaken their regular
physical lives so let's just take the
almost out of it and make sure that
people entirely forsake their physical
lives and just walk around with these
goggles on their face where they lived
in a virtual world where they become
like literally consumed by the internet
so
that's
mark zuckerberg's project is to do that
meanwhile
elon musk is doing this
you know he's buying twitter trying to
protect free speech he's going into
space think of think of the just the
contrast there between the two rich guys
one is like he's trying to make your
life even smaller
removing you even from your physical
environment
so that your your horizons are not just
diminished but actually extinguished so
you can no longer see the horizon
anymore and for elon musk on the other
hand it's expanding our horizons going
out discovering more of the physical
universe that we all live in
um
and that's a great thing but the left
hates him and they hate him even though
tesla is by the way doing more to save
the environment if the environment needs
saving at all then he's doing more to
save it than any certainly any company
in the world and also certainly any
government in the world
but they hate him
primarily and really solely because he
could use his vast wealth to stifle
dissident voices
that would dissident voices as far as
the left is concerned
voices that the left thinks are
dissident
um he could use his wealth to do that
and he could be a huge asset
in their camp
in squashing these voices but he's not
he's going the other direction
he's trying to expand free speech give
more people a platform to speak and have
their voices heard and they hate him for
that
that is his great crime as far as
they're concerned
um all right this is from cnn republican
representative marjorie taylor greene of
georgia was confronted in court on
friday over past social media posts
advocating violence against democrats
allegedly this is cnn's this is cnn's uh
version of events at the hearing in
atlanta determine if green is
constitutionally barred from running for
re-election because of her alleged role
in january 6 erection the congresswoman
repeatedly said she couldn't remember
past comments or interactions cnn's
k-file reported last year prior to being
elected to congress green had repeatedly
indicated support for executing
prominent democratic politicians in 2018
and 2019 in comments and posts on social
media this again is is cnn's claim
um and i would not believe it for a damn
second until they give
proof of it at the hearing green
initially denied she had called house
speaker nancy pelosi a traitor to our
country
which even if she did so what
i mean i call nancy pelosi a traitor to
our country too because she is
in many ways
um and then it went on from there and
they're they're
this is what they're trying to do is
they're trying to as it says in the
article it's like though actually the
one
honest thing the one truthful thing that
i read in the article so far is that
they want to legally bar
uh marjorie taylor green from seeking
reelection
which by the way they wouldn't even
consider doing if they thought they
could just defeat her at the ballot box
but they don't think they can and so
they're going this route instead
a lot of video a lot of clips have
surfaced from this whole kangaroo trial
this was my favorite moment though the
way that marjorie taylor green handled
this listen to this
and
when you
were notified
that people had entered the capitol
illegally did you also understand that
point that there had been violence at
the capitol
i only knew what i was told i'd heard
i'd heard a gunshot we all heard it
and
we were so confused we thought antifa
was breaking in or blm because of those
were the riots that had gone on and on
all throughout 2020 day in and day out
uh just horrible riots all over the
country and that was the only thing that
made sense to most of us
i love that that's great because like of
course she didn't actually think that
antifa and blm was
breaking in
um but that's just her way of bringing
up an important point that
that's the rioting that happened those
those are the riots that we should be
worried about
that plagued uh not just dc for a couple
of hours on one day but plagued cities
across the country for months and even
years on end
so that was her way of bringing that up
which i just think is is great
the part that's not so great about this
is that the left
while they accuse everybody else of of
waging war on democracy they call
everything an attack on
democracy and they're doing it right now
with the situation in florida with
disney
so taking away this a mega corporation a
billion dollar mega corporation's tax
benefits
and simply saying to use their words you
have to pay your fair share
like everybody else does
so that's an attack on democracy that's
an attack on the constitution
and they they make that claim
and are in fact supported by a lot of
conservatives as they make it a lot of
conservatives are joining arms with the
left on that point and saying that yes
this is a
let's let's let's all link arms and
circle around disney
you shall not pass
while they're saying that
just you go north
you know a few hundred miles and here
they are in atlanta trying to bar
one of their opponents from seeking
re-election
what pretense
but because she had offensive tweets
allegedly in 2019
accusing her of like somehow being
involved in the rioting
of fomenting insurrection even though
there was no insurrection
and she obviously wasn't in and the
writing that did occur she wasn't
involved in it
and at no point
did she stand in front of a crowd and
say yes everyone let's go invade the
capital she never said that
so they there's
they're searching for a presence but
they don't really even need it and they
know that because the media is going to
have their backs
and um they're just trying to bar
an opponent who they can't defeat in the
ballot box instead they're going to go
to court and try to stop her
from seeking re-election if if we could
call anything an attack on democracy
this is it
but you know what on the other hand
um
here i am complaining about it
and so conservatives have been
complaining about it and some
republicans a lot of republicans have
just kept their mouth shut about this
because they don't want to um establish
republicans and so on
you know they don't want to be seen
taking marjorie taylor green's side
so they're just putting nails in their
own coffin because if you allow them to
do this to her then they're going to do
it to you next
and you might say well i'm not like her
i'm different i'm i'm i'm one of the
good ones
now as far as the left is concerned
there are no good ones on our side
but rather than complaining about it
you know
since they have
set this standard now
and they've said these are the rules now
that you can bar someone from seeking
re-election
if you can tie them to a riot
no matter how precarious
that connection happens to be well if
those are the rules then great
let's play by those rules
see what we have to stop doing is
allowing the left to have their own
rules
of course they're going to take they're
going to take that privilege speaking of
privileges they're going to take that
privilege if we give it to them
and for years for decades we have given
it to them we've basically said yeah you
can have you can do it that way you can
play by those rules we're too good for
that
so we're going to we're going to lose
with dignity year after year decade
after decade
while our culture and society are
destroyed and children are destroyed and
the family is destroyed
and our civilization collapses uh we're
gonna let all that happen uh because
because you know it's just it's the
dignified thing to do
no these are the rules now
so rather once we're done complaining
about it could complain about it a
little bit and then once we're done that
um now we we flip it around and we say
we we find every single democrat
who actually
encouraged and fomented writing blm
writing for months on end and we do the
same to them
why every single one of them should be
up on the stand every single one of them
should be dragged into court
the entire squad this is what the
republicans should be doing trying to
legally bar them from ever seeking
reelection because of how they encourage
rioting
and they actually did
explicitly
i mean they they were uh aoc and
ilhanomar and all the rest of them doing
doing
instagram lives and stuff like that
saying calling for more unrest there has
to be unrest in the streets and all that
kind of stuff
so rather than simply complaining about
it these are the rules
if you can tie a politician to rioting
then you can
um
proceed to bar them from running for
re-election okay well that
that puts a lot of democrats on the
docket that puts a lot of them on the
hot seat
unless we decide we're too good for that
and and the right thing and the moral
thing is just to allow this to be a tool
that only your enemies use
yet another tool that they use
to devastate and decimate you
while you stand by and watch
because somehow it's dignified or
something
um
so there's a lot of outrage
right now at publix the grocery store um
that supposedly is the grocery store
supposedly some of their some of the the
sponsors of the florida anti-groomer
bill received some donations from publix
i don't even know if that's true or not
but it did lead to this which is pretty
funny
um this is from a leftist activist jack
patakis
said he pronounced his last name who
knows i'm sure i butchered it he says
today i resigned from publix after four
years of service i was so disheartened
when the company failed to even make a
statement following more than 200
thousand dollars in donations to the
sponsors of the
quote unquote don't say gay bill
let's all call on publix to stop funding
hate now this this guy jack this is like
a kid okay so he's not what he says he
resigns from publix he's not on he's not
in the corporate side of it he's not a
you know a vp or something
this this kid's like a cashier
he's bagging groceries and he just he
just uh announced his resignation i like
just just
some news for you
um you don't get to resign from jobs
resigning you have to be i'm gonna put
the cut off at 25 or over at least
and you have to be making more than
minimum wage to resign
when you're like 16 years old
pushing carts around the parking lot
which by the way is a very noble job but
you're doing that you're bagging
groceries you don't get to resign you
just quit
and not only did you quit from your job
but you made a big public statement
about it
and you're blasting your former employer
and that's something that
prospective future employers are going
to see and they're going to be a little
bit reluctant now to hire you as well
they should be
i resign
uh no you just quit kid that's all you
did you just quit your job
meanwhile on the florida bill randy
weingarten who's the
head of one of the largest teachers
unions in the country she was on msnbc
and she had some thoughts on the florida
bill let's listen to those
have you had conversations with lgbtq
teachers in terms of how they have been
targeted uh just for merely existing in
the classroom i mean
i remember teachers just openly talking
about personal experiences and what
they've gone through and now we're
seeing how by merely existing they have
been targeted and smeared as a danger to
their students
so you know obviously
um i have and i've talked to several gay
teachers who are members of our union
um to just um you know be their backstop
um pflag did an amazing um petition
for one of those teachers in florida
a remarkable elementary school teacher
kindergarten teacher
beloved by his kids and
and and the parents of his kids and he
was immediately terrorized
after the bill was passed and signed by
desantis
because he's gay
we have to let
gay kids
and gay teachers frankly we have to let
everyone talk about their lived
experience that's part of how you build
relationships that's part of how you
unite people that's part of how you save
a democracy
of course she got it all in there
i was we got lived experience
and i was waiting could we get one or a
couple other things on the bingo
card
uh and she got saved democracy so she
got there that in there too so we got
lived experience save democracy
um she didn't i was hoping for the
january 6th tie-in and we didn't get
that
but we did of course get homophobia stop
hate so i think there's enough for a
bingo there
um
we have to we have to allow people to
talk about their lived experiences yeah
well this is not the anti-lived
experience bill
um
i wish it was i wish it was a bill
banning people from even using the
phrase lived experience that's another
thing that i would do if i was in charge
but it's not so there is nothing in the
bill which stops anyone from talking
about their lived experiences
it doesn't even stop teachers from
talking about their own lived
experiences even though they should not
be talking about their lived experiences
because that's not why the kids are
there they're not there to learn it's
not story time where they're learning
stories about your lived experience
they're there to learn um the academic
subjects that you ostensibly supposedly
are supposed to be teaching them
then what we get from the msnbc anchor
this uh line of this is another thing
that goes on the bingo card
attacked for merely existing
how often do we hear this this is always
the line
lgbt people are being attacked from
merely existing
no this is a bill and the whole
anti-grooming effort on the right
is targeting actions
certain unacceptable behaviors and
actions and very specifically in this
case the action of sexually
indoctrinating
children so are you saying
as the msnbc anchor are you saying
that
sexually indoctrinating kids
is such a crucial part of the lgbt
identity
it's such a part of the culture that if
you take that away from them you have
you have essentially removed their
ability to exist
are you saying that the existence of
the lgbt community
depends on indoctrinating and recruiting
kids into it is that what you're saying
that's i'm not saying that that appears
to be what you are saying
which is an interesting claim from you
something worth thinking about perhaps
um next taylor lorenz has
i think been workshopping some excuses
for why she decided to dox libs of tick
tock
and she appeared on cnn over the weekend
and this is the excuse that she has
settled on let's listen to it and see if
it's convincing at all
it's rare to see an account
gain so much prominence so quickly and
be shaping these narratives in such an
effective way especially against trans
people um so i was i mean my story was
kind of long but i really wanted to make
the case like why this account mattered
and i think it's incredibly important
you know as someone that covers the
influence or industry to know who is
exerting influence in in this way i mean
for all we knew this could have been a
foreign actor right or someone we just
didn't know and so i thought hey look
this account has massive power massive
influence this woman is basically on an
entire right-wing media tour she gave
interviews to the new york post tucker
all of that um and registered as a media
company uh registered a trademark so
yeah i wanted to i thought it was quite
important and in the public interest to
find out who was running it so there are
several arguments against your article
one is that this person's identity was
simply not newsworthy
oh those are those are dumb arguments of
course not newsworthy well she says uh
that was the interesting thing is that
she says well this person could have
been a foreign actor could have been
some kind of
foreign agent could have been um could
have been a foreign government this was
this was an attempt by a foreign
government maybe libs of tick tock is a
is a creation of the chinese government
or something or no well putin of course
maybe this was putin himself was behind
libs of tick tock
maybe
and i tell you this right now this is
the one concession i will make on behalf
of
of
taylor lorenz and anybody else who
agrees with this
if it had turned out that putin was
running lives of tick tock then i would
agree
that that would be newsworthy okay
that's worth writing a news article
about
but
before you published the article you
discovered that it was not putin and it
was not a foreign agent and uh it was
not anybody it was not any kind of
shadow shadowy figure it was just some
it was just a woman just a regular woman
and so you you discovered that
this was a regular private citizen an
american citizen
no known ties to russia although i'm
sure you're looking for him
but uh you haven't found him yet
and you discovered that and yet you
decided to publish the article anyway
and that's the best she could do that's
the best she could do in justifying
doxing this woman
is that maybe she was a foreign agent
but she wasn't
like the most that that excuse could get
you
is justifying looking into it
which i don't think it even justifies
that
because there's no reason to think
that that a foreign government would
have to be involved in this
what liberals take tick tock does is is
uh as i've said many times is important
and also i imagine time consuming but
also pretty simple
it's like all she's doing is just
looking at tik-tok and then taking the
videos that are the most outrageous and
putting them over here
there's no reason to think that there's
any kind of
government funding behind it
but if that gets you anywhere it just
gets you to the point of looking into it
if even that far
it certainly does not get you to the
point of publishing the article
um with the person's name attached
let's get out of the comment section
[Music]
you know it's exhausting uh just living
in this culture and dealing with all the
things that we talk about in the show
every single maybe even listening to the
show sometimes is exhausting and that's
why you need a helix mattress helix
sleep has a quiz that takes just two
minutes to complete and matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you why would you
buy a mattress made for somebody else
with helix you're getting a mattress
that you know will be perfect for you
and the way that you sleep everybody's
unique and helix knows that so they have
several different mattress models to
choose from they have soft medium and
firm mattresses mattress is great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot
mattress is great for spinal alignment
to prevent morning aches and pains so if
you're looking for a mattress you take
the quiz you order the mattress that
you're matched to and the mattress comes
right to your door and it's shipped for
free it's as easy as that you don't ever
need to go to a mattress store again
helix is awesome but you don't need to
take my word for it helix was awarded
the number one best overall mattress
pick of 2020 by gq and wired magazine
all you got to do to find out why is go
to helixsleep.com walsh take their two
minute sleep quiz and they'll match you
to a customized mattress that will give
you the best sleep of your life
guaranteed they have a 10 year warranty
and you get to try it out 100 nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't want it but you will
helix even has financing options and
flexible payment plans so a great
night's sleep is never far away helix is
offering up 200 off all mattress orders
and two free pillows for our listeners
at helix sleep dot com slash walsh
that's helix sleep dot com slash walsh
for up to 200 off and two free pillows
connor noonan says matt as the world's
leading lgbtq plus author we the people
demand that dw kids has a johnny the
walrus cartoon
well i've the peop i've read this
comment many times and the people are
demanding it i'm demanding it also
not that my demands really mean anything
around here
anyway but i will make the demand
um
let's see
matilda says i think it's weird that
people are so concerned about disney
losing privileges in florida it's not as
if they're being sanctioned they're just
not being coddled anymore if their
special tax rules have been in place for
almost 60 years they should have been
reevaluated by the state either way
not just rolled on for it for eternity
and right you would think the people
especially people who are so critical of
of big corporations and so suspicious of
rich people you think that they
especially would say let's look into
this let's not just
what so keep it going in perpetuity
these tax privileges it's at least time
to re-evaluate
i agree with you on that
um
elizabeth ball says dang what a shame
for the price of one gallon of gas you
get a month of incredible satire content
so rage inducing that watching it burns
more cal watching it burns more calories
than a workout
and all the little side stories that
weren't important enough for the real
media
rip yeah cnn plus another tragedy it is
it is a tragedy uh in many ways
um
connor says i already read that one okay
here's this one it says matt
jt says matt you used to be a christian
but now all you do is stoop to the
left's level i'm extremely disappointed
and have almost completely stopped
listening
please go back to who you were before
um
i always find these kinds of comments
interesting because first of all i've
always been like this
so i'm not exactly sure what you're
talking about
i don't like it when people try to start
rumors that there was a time when i used
to be much more gentle and kind of a
nice guy that i assure you that was
never the case
as far as stupid to the left level
um
yeah you know what that's exactly what
i'm doing
i think there are a lot of people on the
right who agree with who take the same
approach as me and they would take issue
with you describing it as stooping to
their level
but i don't take issue with it you know
in fact i'll i'll accept that
i'm stooping to the level why am i doing
that because um
because that's where they are
right
if i want to land some blows i got to be
where they are
okay
if they're stooping down in the mud in
the muck and i'm standing up here and i
don't want to get my hands dirty
i could swing away all i want and i'm
just gonna be punching the air because
there's nobody there
and i think so often with conservatives
you want to fight battles the way they
were fought 40 or 50 years ago
when it comes to political and
ideological issues
and you're you're basically you're
fighting an opponent that who doesn't
exist anymore
you're fighting a version of the left
that no longer exists
and so if you want to
make any kind of impact at all
and win any battles then you gotta go
where that your opponents are and fight
them there
and if the battlefield's a little bit
muddy and uh and it's it's it's a little
bit ugly well that's just that's how it
is that's the world we live in right now
that's the culture we live in
so yes i absolutely stoop to their level
i i will accept that and i make no
apologies for it
well if you've been living under a rock
and you haven't heard the six million
times i've mentioned it on this show
then you might be unaware that i've
written a children's book and it is
changing the world as we know it it's
sold out in less than 24 hours and at
one point was crowned the number one
best-selling lgbtq plus book on amazon
the book is called johnny the walrus and
i'm sure it will serve as an inspiration
for the entire lgbtq plus community for
centuries to come as mentioned the book
sold out right away due to its immense
popularity but i have great news for you
the book will be back in stock tomorrow
it's finally happening it's finally here
that's why you need to head to
johnnythewalrus.com
and reserve your copy right now now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
you know there is some symmetry to the
show today we started with a network tv
morning show celebrating the grooming
and indoctrination of a young boy
we end with something tragically similar
in this case the today's show website
today.com features an article with this
headline
i wanted my son to reject masculine
stereotypes then he fell in love with
tractors all my life i've prided myself
on blurring gender lines but when my
young sons started to gravitate toward
the very things i'd shunned i wasn't
sure what to do
now the column is written by a guy named
jay
dietker whose twitter bio tells us he's
a stay-at-home co-sleeping dad and a
recovering schmuck
that's how he describes himself
and it appears that his recovery is
not going well sadly
jay doing absolutely no favors to
stay-at-home dads who are worried about
negative stereotypes tells us that he
has he's done his best to indoctrinate
his young boy into being as effeminate
as he is but so far it has not gone
according to plan he writes quote
after turning two years old my son
avishai
that's the son's name started demanding
that he only wear tractor shirts and my
mind spiraled into darkness
i catastrophized worst-case scenarios
imagining a world where he fell for
everything stereotypically manly i
envisioned him on a football field
barreling through mega muscled opponents
i imagined him waxing a sports car in a
warm summer day
yeah what a nightmare that would be
dear god imagine if your son becomes
athletic strong talented and financially
successful
who would want such a thing
who who would wish for such a curse upon
their son well certainly not house
husband jay who continues
i've always judged other guys who seemed
boxed in by masculinity but three and a
half years ago when i became a
stay-at-home dad my bias skyrocketed we
co-slept and he snoozed with his head
resting on my chest listening to the
rhythm of my heartbeat i began attending
mommy and me play groups and bristled
when other caregivers made jokes about
me providing daddy
daycare well at least we could take
solace in the assurance that the moms at
the play group are bullying jay
i kind of imagine him sulking in a
corner eating activia yogurt and crying
softly to himself
and that thought at least brings me some
joy house husband jay continues i
grimaced at anyone driving a ford car
the john wayne of automobiles i hated
men who wore plaid
how dare you sir
i felt ill if somebody mentioned a
wrench or another tool when my
mom-in-law bought avishai a coverall
with footballs on it i shoved it into
the depths of his closet never to be
found
well this is some more good news for me
i guess i'm always looking to pad my
victim resume you know and kind of pad
my stats a little bit and now i know
that i've been discriminated against for
being a member of the plaid community a
person of plaid as we call ourselves pop
for short
at least not be discriminated against by
one person and he just so happens to be
a man who actually wrote the sentence i
felt ill if somebody mentioned a wrench
and he didn't mean it as a joke
let's read just one more section of what
is certainly at least in the running for
the title of most pathetic diatribe in
human history he continues once my son
could walk i paraded him through the
park while he rolled his baby doll down
the sidewalk in his stroller
i felt accomplished because he mirrored
being a caretaker
but then came the tractors
it started with youtube one on days i
was especially drained i'd sit avishai
in front of the tv and click on little
baby bum
he fell in love with the tractor songs
and i was so worn i didn't care
when he asked to watch clips of
construction equipment i mindlessly
pressed play
but when he demanded the shirts
i felt like i failed him i pride myself
on blurring gender lines i wanted him to
also
okay i take it back this is not in the
running for the most pathetic diatribe
in human history
it has certainly won the title all other
competitors are left in its dust
house husband jay talks about his
toddler discovering tractors the way
that that most parents might talk about
their teenage son developing a heroin
addiction or something
he's devastated by it though as the
piece drones on and on and on and on uh
the house husband eventually does come
around to sort sort of accepting his
son's masculine tendencies he's at least
accepted that he can't completely
deprogram his boy and turn him into a
into a girl yet though i suspect he's
not gonna stop trying
for now though and for this foreseeable
future his toddler son is manlier than
he is and he felt the need to write an
article and post it on today.com and let
us all know about that
now it's hard not to laugh at house
husband jay
um he certainly deserves all of the
mockery and bullying coming his way if
only he'd gotten a whole lot more of it
in his youth maybe it wouldn't have come
to this
but the laughter soon dies away when you
remember that there's an actual real
child caught in the middle of this
neutered man's self-hating neurosis
and it demonstrates again
one startling fact
that on the left
there's only one rule for children
okay they can be anything they want to
be
but they must become something other
than what they actually are
they must be raised to reject themselves
their true nature their authentic
identities
so it's not that and this is important
it's not that on the left it's not that
they hate masculinity per se
even jay himself who faints and vomits
at the sight of a socket wrench doesn't
despise the idea of masculinity he just
despises it when it's exhibited by men
he quite admires masculinity in women
which is why he's traded place with his
places with his wife and ceded the man's
role to her
leftists certainly don't have a problem
with brawny masculinity or pink and
frilly femininity
they just have a problem with those
things in their traditional settings
boys can be as friendly and feminine as
they like girls can be as masculine as
they like
the only time a girl should be
traditionally feminine is if
uh it's actually a boy identifying as a
girl just as the only time a boy should
be masculine is if the boy is actually a
girl identifying as a boy
the left has not waged war on
masculinity and femininity directly it
has instead ripped these things out of
their proper context and had them sort
of switch places with each other
now inevitably
both will perish in that operation just
as any tree dies when severed from its
roots
as maleness is the life-giving root of
masculinity and femaleness is the root
of femininity but it's important to note
just just how they've gone about doing
this
it's also essential to realize that
in a very strange and backwards sort of
way
leftists actually worship femininity and
masculinity
perhaps fetishize is a better word
that's what all the drag queen stuff is
about
they just don't like either femininity
or masculinity when they are found in
females and men respectively
they want to switch those two things
so the theme as always
is that people must reject who they are
be anyone you want to be
other than yourself
that's the core message it's the
religion that this man's son will be
tragically indoctrinated into
and that is ultimately why housewife j
is today canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo vadosky
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
joe biden stuns the nation by mixing up
mass mandates with title 42 controversy
continues to swirl around florida ending
a special tax giveaway for disney and
twitter reverses course to reconsider
elon musk's often as today on the bench
bureau show give it a listen